[Musique]
bonsoir
et voici maintenant notre émission
dramatique du samedi soir si vous voulez
mademoiselle je voudrais m'adresser aux
speakerine qui arrive à beaucoup
d'améliorations apportées ci voulait
recommencer montrent qu'ils vous allait
m'annoncer par exemple un match de boxe
nous allons voir s'il faut que ça bouge
trouve du move on a guetté alesi et
voici maintenant un match de bon
attendez monter un petit piège abonder
qu'à c'est qu'est ce que vous voulez
faire prise au début de reprise que ce
que je fais ce que l'on me alors c'est
très simple je sens comme d'habitude
oui mon petit quartier balancer plus à
mon petit ce qu'il faut faire je vais
vous dire c'est le annoncé gaiement un
peu de musique ça fait passer le temps
musique s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
nous allons vous nantais
tu
c'est bien maintenant essayer une
émission politique alors c'est très
simple et voici maintenant controverse
ou deux personnalités politiques
importantes vont se confronter aux mon
petit ça c'est d'une tristesse de l'opac
guerre en soi ainsi vous l'annoncer
comme ça c'est s'ils disent non nous
allons c'est eux et envoyer le générique
de notre émission controverse s'il vous
plaît de soins soit j'ai la gorge que
très moche j'ai la droite
maladroits les centres risquent bientôt
de radical qui va mal voici maintenant
notre émission dramatique du samedi elle
a repoussé par la tête et les pieds
toute façon c'est plus grave
mais non alors je vais m'en occuper moi
même comme je suis tout ici et voici
maintenant notre émission dramatique du
samedi soir
kaka vtz d'après ce qu'elle va cherche
oui mais ça c'est un style nouveau toute
chose pouvoir aller vite jugée loin un
avion prix forfaitaire pour deux mois
les retours avec des fonctions
fromage ou dessert quart de vin conduite
c'est très avantageux
je suis très ému parce que c'est le jour
émouvant du départ et c'est mon premier
reportage qui voyagent à une amie qui
vient dire au revoir son fils et ma
réponse quel amour
fortis margot on s'est trop gentilles
est revenue sur les profiter des
photographes tels photographes ne me
fait pas rire j'ai vu ton beau frère non
c'est ça va sentir seul si loin à
tonnage alors je demande à mon monde se
précise son châle on sait jamais assez
les courants d'air avec un arthro c'est
gentil mais tu n'aurais pas dû courir
comme ça soit un visage tout ravages
m'en inquiète pas pour ta copine elle a
du ressort
je suis prêt les bulldogs d'âme quand on
a alors que jean d'amour je suis sata
sont les gentils ils ont mis un temps
fou à toi parce qu'en ce moment je
trouve un peu à peu on fera bon signe
mesdames si vous anticipez sauver le
soul du décollage résultats qui n'ont
pas l'habitude d'être là qu'elle chérit
plus je partirai si ma contrée je te
concis pas assez jolie ce que tu viens
de dire c'est très joli que je sors mon
but maintenant par ici c'est énervant
c'est long c'est très émouvant au bon
dieu
au revoir au revoir ma chérie miller
bien du tout les soirs à 8h30 ce
mercredi en revanche air et bon voyage
je leur dirai tout ce que je pense de
toi je viens courir mais pourquoi ils
ont déjà enlevé la passerelle
recommandant de sa taille sont bientôt
d'allemand mais j'ai un problème j'ai un
problème j'ai descendu et j'ai descendu
avec le train le train devient fort
madame qu'est ce que vous racontez
chetrat coincé c'est tout sinon ça que
vous avez une grande des mains vous en
prie même c'est d'un gouffre du train
d'atterrissage qui sera pas si nous
ratons phrase en hongrois vient cesse de
train-train paysage sous les élevé qui
se déploie comme ça et c'est ce sur quoi
on atterrit la piste c'est par terre
pour qu'on se pose par terre il faut que
l'avion le train pour respirer et ne
sortent pas mal mais bon passons
c'est pour ça fait bouger la notice et
les bassins de faire tout ça mais ça ne
marche pas à appuyer sur le bouton x
tous des compresseurs 4,36 desserrer le
16 aux tirs et la manette 26e clignotant
rouge clignote poêle à bois hélas cet
enfant tient tellement ça marche pas le
commandant une marche non mais je
constate monsieur le temps
d'atterrissage d'un avion ça sort
toujours en marche
alors n'allez pas me dire ça mais c'est
du temps de rien faire quelques 7 celui
là ça c'est cet hymne à côté vous avez
peut-être c'est lent et pour ceux qui
constateront forces de l'ennemi bon et
celui là ça c'est le rite aussi bon et
ça c'est l'allume-cigare madame mais
alors elle traque des sorties autres
habitants je vois très bon mais madame
je vous dis que ça ne peut pas regarder
s'appuie sur tous les boutons ça ne
signe pas ça devrait clignoter sortie je
le ferais pas ça qui ne traite à ne
clignote pas
ben écoute alors atterri ci se fera
milliard en revenus ce serait pareil je
vous dis qu'on ne peut pas atterrir sans
plus l'atterrissage s'est fait une heure
que j'essaie de vous expliquer matin on
va retourner en rose et épuisement de
carburant- afex vous voulez on se posera
sur le ventre la comédienne que je fis
ne s'est jamais posée sur un bon pour
une fois mon uramin meilleure chose à
proposer du savagnin
samedi 72 cette année je vais vous dire
enfin pas fanfaronner brésil
quand je vous dis qu'on tournait en rond
et d'écouté on peut pas se débarrasser
du carburant entre la vole aussi avec
appuyer sur le bouton lavoyer arabe a
auditionné annonce à dire on appuyé par
un pigeon ce qu'il faut là bas et en
haut des tours suite à force c'est un
homme a tellement chez nous avant
d'envisager toutes les solutions
on pourrait peut-être essayer de parler
à cet appareil en langue étrangère
non vous avez raison
ce bel oiseau à cette réunion semblait
parlement vient pas du tout porté bien
qu'il ait tenté de recherche google sur
le alors avoué saisie mais moi je ne
sais pas pour les sacs sont construites
barbezieux parce qu'il ya là bas mais
c'est tout arrêter ne vous énervez pas
le connaît la langue il va comprendre
moi ce bel oiseau blanc ce bel oiseau
d'un tueur c'est la poésie
jacques robin ou se présenter où je sais
cela vous fait l'atout trail pour
charmer le bel oiseau blanc et pour
charmer la tourterelle le bel oiseau
blanc et là vous mari ne nous fait
naturel non eloi tonneau festif et se
fait par dieu et la rousse est clair
gagner ça clignote mais non mes amis à
plumes applaudi si c'était le premier
c'est le premier mais amusé kim et
résiste au matin
et au bac s et bien victoire pour madame
nous sommes mitoyenne peu de choses nous
sépare
je souhaite bonne nuit à malone est pas
trop fatigué je suis vraiment posé
couché dans deux minutes avec la bosnie
fait au bâton mieux je vous souhaite une
bonne nuit
j'espère qu'on n'allait pas sortir nous
avons une longue où je voulais en forme
qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que vous ayez
machine et puis tu imagines rien mais
nous sommes arras des gaz des boîtes de
nuit et machines à sous il ya des
tentations pour un grand jeu l'homme
graves mais il en faut plus que ça on me
tentait sans c'était et bien dans quel
état nous sommes oui nous ne sommes pas
du jour c'est moi donc il dit moi je
vous souhaite une bonne nuit bon ça
[Musique]
vous sortez 1,2828 were ce qui peut
laisser supposer une chose pareille n'a
jamais passé obtenu ces masses et racine
montée jama du soir à c'est très très
chic chic
oui et le nez papillon je suis fragile
de la gorge stress le jeu en général à
mi-chemin un médecin trouve ce plus
grand qu'une petite laine oui c'est très
bien c'est joli mais vous même à bas
coût devraient y faire attention
chemise de nuit un peu dégueu mais où je
vois mieux vous avez dit elle ressemble
à une robe du soir ont pas du tout un
but mais c'est lourd c'est nouveau c'est
fait exprès comme ça des décors d'été
qu'on se lève les soins dès qu'on sort
du lit on est tous tu t'habilles et on
va se dire ces pratiques qu'est ce que
vous faites dans des soirées bien
qu'est-ce que je fais ta vie ah bah si
j'étais venu pour retourner ma petite
pancarte
d'où notre histoire ne pas déranger ce
que j'ai horreur de déranger le matin
par la femme de ménage qui veut
absolument faire votre lit quand vous
êtes dedans en train de dormir et
désagréable je vais vous faire rire
j'avais eu la même idée
je me suis dit tiens ma petite coco city
sorti ce fut effectivement pour tourner
et à titre en jeu la retourner le pont
profiter c'était banny à badaroux
[Musique]
allô allô allô c'est madame aussi victor
le selector madame mais que se passe
t'il une insomnie et pas du tout madame
j'avais le sentiment de vous avoir dit
bonsoir un peu sèchement je tenais à
m'en excuser parce que j'ai peur d'avoir
des revoir que ça m'empêche de dormir
que charmante pensée victo je vous en
remercie beau s est naturellement ce que
je voulais c'est parce que nous sommes y
faire commence à faire un peu lisse et
moi aussi je serais je souhaite la bonne
nuit douce à bouton poussoir la merci
beaucoup
on va faire du bien de se coucher ou au
lit à l'eau
alors nos victoires à l'hô pital au loot
sommes entendus ce matin
oui je vous demande pardon madame j'ai
oublié d'enlever mes boules quiès ont
écouté je voulais vous dire que votre
coup de téléphone tout à l'heure m'a
touché un minimum je vais vous en
remercie vivement et c'est tout naturel
sherman ans était très très très gentil
j'en suis tout bouleverser encore je
suis gentil remettez vos boules et
dormait tranquillement je vous remercie
je compte sur go soit madame bonamie
[Musique]
c'est le nom c'est ainsi que c'est moi
c'est trop cher et beau pays
vous savez j'étais sorti joli chaos que
tu es ste marguerite ya oublie de mettre
des chaussures dans le coup lors
pourquoi ici à s'écouter vous êtes vous
allé vers lui
parce que je viens porter les miens
exactement brunch ou alors que c'est un
museau en avril on a des choses oui je
sais bien mais les vois je me demande si
cela paie et bridge a joué le bruit
parce qu'il ya un peu de lumière dans le
marbre du tout je ne sais pas licencier
pas seulement pour tirer tous les jours
a terni employé dans l'hôtellerie
ce matin que je suis content que ce soit
madame mon dieu je me disais je le sais
j'ai dit au revoir madame tout à l'heure
je vais même pas serré la main c'est
roger m'a traumatisée non je n'ai pas
heureusement que c'est madame des deux
fils avait été quelqu'un d'autre sur le
rbe est en effet bien écouter non soyez
roja n'avait que j'ai peur j'ai peur
qu'on n'en sortent pas alors je vais
vous dire une bonne chose l'isq vous
êtes en pyjama du soir espoir chez les
moins riches mise de nuit
cette offre est maudit la nuit voilà
alors aussi nous fassions la nuit
ensemble
comment au cabaret à rêver et balance
ses abords
voici les indicateurs classiques attend
que bien qu aux attentes de tous c'est
un très grand honneur pour moi d
inaugurer ce soir c'est colossal temple
de l'art lyrique le in spirit à d'une
bande qui est et à total en accompagnant
la tri célèbre cantatrice et
international maya n'a qu'à le freeline
et les non moins célèbres sylvaner
auguste dans ce merveilleux les peines
lipson du soliste n'y a ni spa foulquier
mayan a cappella libanais bousculent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
[Applaudissements]
la nuit descend sur la tête pour le
match à caen propose écrasé bienne rue
la raison comme et allons nous coucher
[Musique]
dubaï
une union la langue et les enfants une
journée type elle
qui vient faire là qu'elle est souvent
aussi dérisoire fils bon vous me
racontiez toi toi les filles de tomber
pour amr chobaki seulement sa visite m'a
complètement clos fait bien dangereux
juge si on à rennes sa mère lui ce pas
là la fumée et toi tu pourras toujours
le sus allaitement toi toujours signée
tu me dis que je te donne un grand coup
de poing de joie non demain se réjouit
alors monolines le travail qu'ils
livrent maintenant quatre ans de bail
mais je me suis racheté discale à des
designers je le reconnais bien là avec
sa délicatesse
en quoi mon traitement qui incendient
toujours y eu des prix du pétrole
la flamme est plus généreuse
selon sa mère c'est l'enfer
c'est ce qu'on appelle la mitad mois on
pourrait donner le rôle de la mère à
jouer j'en aurais fait davantage au
retur ça passe tractations j'ai craqué
aucune subtilité mes chiens écoutez moi
qui ne comprend pas le russe comprend
très peu le russe rényon regarde par la
fenêtre
il ya quelque chose en pilier non s'ils
ne connais pas ton frère ton benjamin
qui veut bien dire est qu'ils sont
inconscients au feuillet s'est bien
battu le tu ne cherches pas à gauche se
couche
oui oui ça bush s'en fout ça bouge plus
c'est pas moche que je l'avais pas
reconnu
et là c'est humain grade i have any les
tiens qui le foot anglais c'est fini
c'est oublier qu'il ne recommencera pas
vivant du terrible tu sais mais j'y
pense oui petit prg super vilain petit
papa moi là haut avec la mode il n'a pas
changé
j'écoule mouawad commanderie cmo mal
être de revoir son fils du préfet rey
qui beaucoup ce soir à dos rouge et
peut-être que tu peux avoir
je vais plus bas pour être un jeu l'air
j'étais content je serais lui n'a pas
dit un mot pas desserré les dents
peut-être qu'il ne m'aimait
un père ses besoins au ballet g t d'or
si l'effet des tabacs année complet
était un si grand de fumeurs oui tu les
services militaires
changeons pas failli et 2000 en aval de
bagdad
je n'étais pas là côté la dernière
dernière histoire cela notre alliance et
la radio non sonia la blonde à la du peu
je viens faire qu'une bouchée qu'une
boucherie oui elle n'est pas vaccinée en
fous furieux
j'appuie sans vie d'artiste remarque que
la baisse est la plus connue est la
foule tu ne trouves tu me l'as roma
lamanque liddell s'est ainsi qu une
telle envie si nos solutions et petites
dont il n'a pas dû le rester grands mots
pour la faire la révolution
après cette hécatombe fait gonfler pour
un soupirant demain j'irai faire brûler
un cierge
sheila bair azpeitia aa je te reconnais
bien là plus tard mais plèbe le jeu tu
pars dans ma culture bords du doubs non
je ne suis pas rancunière voilà tout si
c'est ce que tu vas faire
l'élite il va le chercher une casserole
poudre à canon dans le cagibi au rang de
la course mais on peut décrire choses
qui n'ont su score de majid images ont
fait là bas et du boss qui ne verrait
rien dans le noir c'est jusqu'où
comment cette boîte de les mettre et
regarder de très près aux mouches jus
saute il est terrible monument toujours
ta mère
[Musique]
allons nous coucher soit reviendra plus
personne à tuer wallon du budget
j'ai parlé de ces pour la coproduction
préféré plutôt entretenu par les
producteurs napolitains
si c'est ça napolitano des picards et
tient à un constat douille cannelée
pendouille allant de tragédienne france
- grand dam des trois petites
embrouilles avait rien du tout moi la
paix le longer les gros plans pour
qu'elle arrive quedal et qu'au fond rien
de ce qu'a raconté devaient s'affairer à
la goutte d'or enfin seb en italien
allez vous habiller de 20,15 dans la
scénic à la bannière contre la
concentration pour donner le la pour
ceux connaissant très bien moteur de
l'ofce un clapot côté amour entre lucera
la primaire qui n'a été dit l'était
directement dit là je la connais la can
sont ramassés vis aux coûts des vertus
qui ne pigent et des peuples dominés par
des bruits
les rondeurs et à poitiers leurs
dépouilles la chaux des terrains que je
soumets neige à boston a été aux yeux
qui s'amusent à défier les soleils de la
vie claire et honnête découlent de ces
végétaux réuni par l'egypte une fois ils
seront une quinzaine en écoutant
sous-estimé si tu as été baptisés ainsi
taso le cac40 a rouvert sous fourvière
son père et sa cristal avec des îles
santa maria de respecter son riche passé
et que tu veux que je fasse le fouta
carradine et si tu mérites de manama
sinon ils étaient frais à petit et à
26,12 et faire quelque chose est aussi
le nom de menacer la carabine fait ce
passage est un prix n'est souffre est
pas là ma richesse
[Musique]
j'ai sûrement du mal à digérer dans la
peau et que je dois rester célibataire
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'elle regardait et vous jouez
comme vous le sentez comédie à l'épreuve
dès la fonte à l'afp ont éclaté quand
amour et son crochet du fpi marques
[Musique]
déposées c'est pas grave quand khadim lô
faisais mon producteur m'a expliqué qu
est ce que vous faites n'est ce pas dans
cette histoire la confidence de jean à
la station radiophonique en ama et le
stylet pour eux mêmes à nos prisons
mayala sous ses pas les textes auprès de
celui ci alors les petites sommes et à
venir in amoureuse de cet art a dit
l'épousé ou tu la connais de sacre après
que je vais rencontrer soleil la mer
c'était sur la plage il m'avait plus que
nous que depuis mon nom dessus pop avait
des bruits sur le réalisateur c'est
presse qui doit jouer ce rôle là c'est
moi et est la confidente mach vider les
mots ta grossesse car ils ont beaucoup
ce moment là de manière que dans le
travail et on s'affaire à divers travaux
faits par ces gros bonnets mariano c'est
dommage est obligé de donner ta
partition à la signorina france y un
mois plus tôt plus les paranos au
travail à la clinique en ambulance à
rester aux cliniques définitivement
attribuées l'une est un film avec seal
mata santé mayan croit tout le monde des
gens qui nous appellent sont un outil
pâtissant toujours de quoi c'est pour te
remonter les finales un peu le final je
suis sa fermeture en fait ça te redonner
à la morale et à la guyane allait partir
mais alors ça va suffire à vous tous les
matins il clapot
j'ai demandé de gravigny qui ce soir qui
verra son cas la vinière charge les
féminines qui veut dire mon producteur
que vous avez
[Musique]
la conférence que je vais avoir
l'honneur de faire devant vous sous la
présidence honorifique effectué de
monsieur anatole béchard le grand
spécialiste de la sinusite et des
refroidissements et de monsieur pugel
gras le premier al filistini le premier
à monter sur le puy-de-dôme aura trait
aujourd'hui à mon délire exploit comment
j'ai planté le drapeau français au
sommet du mont mama les repas 12 mille
mètres d'altitude
je ne m'étendrai pas davantage sur
moi-même beaucoup d'autres l'ont déjà je
rappellerai brièvement les tricks des
conférences données à l'issue de notre
voyage week end chez les pygmées la
bourboule et son folklore mais vingt
mille lieues sous les mers excepté
rights mx une confession en passe
j'étais un peu las de voyager je décide
le nom de consacrer nous attend à la
rédaction de mon livre de souvenirs qui
doit paraître à incessamment chez
arthème fayard et l'entretien de mozac
de suspense eh bien voyez-vous jeune
bourgeoise un beau matin d'octobre un
plein je voulais jouer au rhume le
professeur les chats rappelé en
consultation le conseil rectitude ma
décision fut prise en à l'instant
j'attaquerai le mouvement manet repas 12
mm
une anecdote aux façons c'était en main
non tu d'une bourse délivrés par les
échanges culturels et du musée de la
femme je décision de partir dans les
plus mauvaises conditions voici mes
gardes mes bagages sont vite fait un
bond trick où on enrôle ont un pot de
saintdo pour enduire melcher est le plus
important le drapeau france offert par
les anciens de la pétanque doublettes
dont vous connaissez tous la devise
prend à boule dans la vague beaucoup
pour éviter des pousses je décidé de
faire de l'auto stop jusqu'à marseille
je ne post est donc au bord de la route
et attendit un véhicule motorisé pour me
rapprocher du tibet au bout de trois
heures un motocycliste me prit en
troupes
un régal irlandais dans sa famille à dix
kilomètres de là et qui m'a fait une
broche pour y passer la nuit
la grande aventure commence
je passais sur les différentes polices
il m'envoya ma journée à béziers
mme baddou gauche ou vers lyon c'était
un travail et c'était toujours la
partenaire
directement auprès dans la petite ville
de où on dernier rate avant l'ascension
deux choses importantes occuper mon
esprit la première acheter des
provisions de bouche partage et la
deuxième trouver des indigènes pour
m'indiquer le meilleur chemin
deux jeunes raj elle s'étend à ma vue
frapper le front avec l'index
ainsi la filtration coutume je pense en
confiance je décide de partir sur le
champ à la première à tous les deux
chercheurs pas s'enfuir en emportant
tout bête mais vêtements je me trouvais
dans seul et nu au pied des neiges
éternelles
mais quid est ma devise va jusqu'au bout
je veux te rappelle en quelques mois la
g partie de ce sommet magie qui
émergeait du monde
une anecdote en passant juge tient à
souligner
il faisait pas le verlan cavernes
d'avalanche au l'avalon je me rapproche
lentement du sommeil à 8500 mètres
d'altitude la bouche ample pompiers dans
une bande velpeau et je continue
toujours joyeuse une anecdote en passant
j'étais furieuse montant vers le savez
nous ne valons chavanges et soudain vous
allez voir c'est impressionnant quand on
est seul à mettre la nature
soudas au détour d'un pic comme comme
vous diriez comme ça il y habiter au
premier tour
il me semble entendre une voix étrange
je pense que ma raison ces gars au sang
se glace dos me gêne serait ce par
hasard l'abominable homme des neiges les
esprits dans les journaux ce qui rend
pas ne l'ont jamais vu jamais touché je
m'approchais jamais touché ça fait très
chaud il m'a simplement derrien rhume
par un pot imposition des pâtes et
grosse panne une chapelle et des mains à
croix je sais pas pas faire de mon
drapeau je lui ai donné si vous savez ce
qu'il en a fait les cent pas ici le
norvégien
j'ai dès maintenant il est abominable
j'arrive
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]